[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the 126th
live stream of the dark horse podcast
i'm dr brett weinstein this is dr
heather heing and we are coming to you
at our regular time which ought to
surprise you all given how much
shuffling we have had to do with our
schedule but uh it's saturday midday
here on the
soggy soggy pacific northwest almost
coast
yeah it's wet
our uh one time colleague uh jack
longino once referred to the pacific
northwest
as the windshield of the continent and
boy does it feel like that these days it
is the windshield and i am a bug
no no no not like that
um
so we are we are here right now as
if you're here you know that already uh
this is gonna be the last time we're
gonna do a live stream for um gosh two
and a half weeks actually because we've
got a lot of
stuff coming up but there will be a few
one at least maybe maybe two uh dark
horse
podcast with brett and a guest coming to
you between now and then and and all
sorts of good stuff coming up if it
would only stop
raining
my god which it does but only for a few
minutes at a time only a few minutes at
a time yeah uh so today we're going to
be talking to you a bit
about uh some
uh new thinking in uh in some covered
space
um brett's going to
talk again about why sophistry is a
scourge and
and we're going to talk about in a
slightly different way than we have
talked about before
some of the values and virtues of being
outside in service of not just our sign
off which is what it is because we
believe it
but also in service of one of one of the
drum beats uh that that we have in our
lives and that we make in the book and
that we make here on on the podcast
is uh that just because you can easily
measure something just because
especially modern science modern
technology modern ways of life have
figured out a way
to identify to separate out and identify
and then perhaps synthesize an augment
in the lab something that is understood
to be valuable does not mean that that
is the valuable thing or the only
valuable thing or that it is as valuable
to you in that form as it would be if it
came with all of the original things
that it came with so
we're going to talk a little bit about
that today actually i strangely see a a
connection a confluence between all of
the various topics that we're talking
about today so yeah i don't know that's
kind of cool when that happens that's no
that's that's
as as we aim for as i am for anyway um
so
um
just some logistics first uh this time
unlike the previous two uh we will be
doing a q a after this so we encourage
you to write in with questions to
www.darkhorsesubmissions
you do need to pay something in order to
write a question but we try to get to as
many of them as possible and any
question that really interests us no
matter what
what what the dollar value it comes in
at we will try to get to and
sometimes if some if there's something
that we really want to get to and we
don't have time we'll we'll forward that
into the next
into the next q a so
uh we do have a q a today uh our next
live stream is going to be on thursday
may 26th
at some point on that day
after both of us will have been a number
of places not here
and
then follow that up right away with
something on may 28th after livestream
128 and then saturday june 4th and then
again saturday june 11th i thought that
may be early because again we've got um
airlines are messing with us and
changing tickets that we already bought
and making things hard that didn't used
to be a thing
that didn't used to be a thing although
um it used to be a thing
here although you know well the story
that
i experienced
uh which i'll just i'll just share here
um so
you know we we talked
two three live streams ago about having
um been blessed to go to the bahamas uh
our first our first vacation in well
over two years and we talked a lot about
the biology and geology of what we saw
there on our recent live stream uh what
we didn't say was actually uh we were
supposed to be there for almost 24 hours
longer than we were there
uh and both of our both of our flights
got like crunched towards one another
and there was nothing to be done about
it and that was disappointing it also
affected you know because we were on a
friend's boat the whole time it affected
what we could do
and you know that didn't used to be a
thing however
back in
1996 i guess it would have been when i
was doing my first long
field season in madagascar i had with me
you were not with me you were actually
doing work in panama on viral colorado
island for most of that i think you
started your season a little bit into
mine and then you were there for for 19
months
but i was there and i had as a field
assistant a wonderful young woman named
jessica uh who was
um who's
i didn't
i don't know what all i'm allowed to say
although i wrote about her in my book
antipode um so yeah jessica's uh dad was
the united nations resident
representative from madagascar and they
were in tana capital city and it was it
was very heartening to know that there
was that
that connection and they would send us
care packages it was i remember you know
when you when you're living in a tent
for five months and
showering at a waterfall and your
company is your wonderful field
assistant and
uh occasional conservation agents and
sort of lemurs and chameleons and frogs
you are desperate if you are me anyway
or jessica for the written word for
language and so they would send us you
know i had i remember i finally read all
of crime and punishment even the troop
movements on that trip
uh but they would send us care packages
with um back copies of the economist
which i'd never read before uh so i
started i started reading and didn't
really continue reading but i read the
economist while living in nosy manga be
in madagascar in 96
but
we you know flew out of her five months
five months had to go to um the offices
of the wildlife conservation society
which sort of
oversee that part of the island which
had recently been made into a national
park and then we're flying back to tana
with i thought about i had about 26
hours to spare before i would then fly
home or in that case my parents were
living in london at the time so i was
flying back to london
and uh we got back to tana the capital
city
and jessica's parents or maybe just her
mom roz uh picked us up at the airport
this is you know after five months in
the field we are we are pretty pretty
grubby and ready for for more human
interaction than each other
and she ra says to me so
your flight's been changed and i just
have this sinking feeling because
already at the beginning of this i'd had
a lot of the equipment that i had
put together and um to make a solar
electricity system had been stolen so
i'd had to go into the streets of tana
and buy a car battery and use that to
set it up to my inverter and all of this
like oh god what now she said well
instead of your flight being 26 hours
from now it's
four hours from now
and uh we scrambled and i you know got
on the plane i got out of there but i
thought
this doesn't normally happen
you know it would have been quite
possible that i could have flown in
expecting that i would just stay at the
airport and make my connection my
international connection but no that
would not in fact have worked yes but
that flight actually i did a little
looking and um it seems to have been 24
hours early but in fact this being air
madagascar it was a flight uh from a
year prior it was a year late
[Laughter]
yes yes yes the aptly named air mad
you're mad mad uh did in fact um you
know get me where i needed to go and it
has every time
with often very little to spare in terms
of sanity or everyone's bags each of our
experiences with air matt they have in
fact maintained cabin pressure despite
the uh
looseness of the seals in the door to
the uh there was the one time that we
were flying together and we were close
enough to the door that we watched the
uh the
stewardess actually sort of seemed to
push the seal back into the deal you
know as you close the door the uh the
weather ceiling needed to be
tucked into the uh
yeah the door yeah no this was yeah this
was to be a flight that would would you
know stop in
oh gosh probably um
djibouti
and munich before landing finally in
paris uh and uh it made it made all of
those and i don't you know the seal
the seal persisted the seal the seal
held yeah we cannot argue
empirically speaking it uh it worked
yeah so anyway
um that was neither here oh that's that
explains why we may be coming to you
early on june 11th which seems a long
time from now um but because uh we
bought some tickets uh for
it doesn't matter uh that have just been
moved up by six hours but what the hell
anyway um if you're watching on youtube
we're also streaming on odyssey that's
where the chat is again you can ask your
questions for the q a that we'll be
doing right after this with a short
break between the two at
www.darkhorseadmissions.com
you can find
my writing at naturalselections.substa
we talked a little bit about one of the
pieces in we came we came to you with
episode 125 just a few days ago in which
we uh focused on talking about the um
the alito the leak out of the supreme
court from the alito opinion
which is a majority opinion which is
likely to overturn roe v wade
so we talked a little bit about um
my most recent sub stack then
and
we also want to as always say that we
are supported by our audience and we
appreciate you so much we appreciate you
subscribing
to the channels and liking and sharing
both the full episodes as you are
watching right now and
also the clips which you can find on
dark horse podcast clips both on youtube
and odyssey and of course we appreciate
financial support from those
who can afford it
you can ask questions in our q a that's
one way you can join one or both of our
patreons brett had a patreon
conversation this morning for two hours
which was as usual i hear coalition of
the reasonable
rising to the challenge on a difficult
topic this morning so anyway it's all
gonna share that no okay nope i think we
have to keep those conversations
private for the protection of all
awesome okay
um
and and of course we have we have
sponsors who
help support us tremendously and
as we've said before all of our sponsors
have products or services that we
actually truly vouch for and in those
cases in those couple of cases where
they are products that we don't
personally have
need for
we won't vouch for them unless we can
independently assess them or have
someone whom we trust do so so without
further ado here we go with our three
sponsors for this week
our first sponsor this week is new to us
it's seed seed is a company focused on
bacteria and the microbiome and has a
terrific probiotic
probiotic
called ds01 daily symbiotic
there are so many actions that you can
take to enhance your health our sign off
here at dark course includes three of
them as as those listening are likely to
be well aware be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside but a
lot is hidden in those words what for
instance constitutes good food
good food is real food whole food food
that has been alive recently and was
grown with care and conditions as
ancient as possible given the
constraints of the 21st century but even
many people who eat such a diet can be
missing something
we contain multitudes every individual
human contains so many other organisms
some of which might harm us but many of
which exist with us in harmony we need
them that is this is why probiotics can
be an important tool and a healthy
lifestyle even if you eat nutrient-dense
food and avoid processed foods and sugar
that said probiotics are in some ways
the new current thing ever heard of
probiotic tortilla chips they were a
thing and no they're not effective good
news though seeds ds01 daily synbiotic
is the real deal
not all probiotics are created equal
seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is broad
spectrum 2 in 1 probiotic and prebiotic
it contains a proprietary formulation of
24 distinct probiotic strains in
scientifically studied dosage
z in a two in one capsule that protects
the probiotics until they hit the colon
where they are most effective if you've
taken a probiotic before and never felt
a difference it's likely because the
good bacteria weren't surviving your gi
tract seed is designed differently and
that's why it works
seeds daily symbiotic supports gut
health including maintenance of the gut
barrier as well as skin and heart health
and micronutrient synthesis
many who have used seed report
improvements to digestive function in 24
to 48 hours
so consider starting a new healthy habit
today visit seed.com darkhorse and use
code darkhorse to redeem 20 off your
first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com darkhorse and
use code darkhorse i always wondered
about the probiotics and making it all
the way to the gut where they would have
to because uh the stomach is designed to
prevent stuff from getting there alive
precisely so i mean i actually i spent
some time looking at their you know this
a lot of that script wasn't from them
that script was from from from me um but
i also spent some time looking at their
site and looking into their claims and
exactly right like what you know the
stomach is designed to break down stuff
um of course many of the things that you
take that um the target is lowered down
in your intestinal system and your gi
tract won't get there and um seeds uh
ds01 daily symbiotic does that's cool
yeah
all right so our second sponsor this
week is eight sleep uh also a relatively
new sponsor for us and we are excited to
know about them and proud to have their
support
good sleep is a game changer as we
discuss in the sleep chapter of
hunter-gatherers guide intelligent life
that found its way to earth might be
surprised by a lot of what it found on
our planet but not by the fact of sleep
or by dreams sleep is necessary without
good sleep we are destined to be
unhealthy and unproductive
yet more than 30 of americans struggle
with sleep and temperature is one of the
main reasons it is well known that
individuals and couples who sleep
together often have different optimal
sleep temperatures age sleep allows
fine-tuned temperature regulation for
both people having a cool worm nope
having a cool room and a warm bed is a
luxury that ate sleep makes easy to
obtain
the pro the pod pro cover by eight sleep
is the most advanced solution on the
market for thermal regulation you can
add the cover to any mattress and start
sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
fahrenheit which is a couple of times
i've read these ads so far i just stop
and think you don't we don't want either
of those but you could
you guys
it's useful for practical jokes
as the person who shares the bed with
you i'm not so pleased with that
revelation
the temperature of the cover will adjust
each side of the bed based on your sleep
stages biometrics and bedroom
temperature reacting dynamically to
create the optimal sleeping environment
eight sleep users fall asleep up to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by 40
and get more restful sleep overall and
with 30 more deep sleep on average that
restorative sleep will likely help with
physical recovery hormone regulation and
mental clarity
finally the alarm feature which can wake
you with temperature change and or
slight chest level of vibrations is so
much gentler than any standard alarm we
were both a little skeptical and are now
totally sold we're surprised at how much
we appreciate this bed
go to
8sleep.comcourse to check out the pod
pro cover and save 150 at checkout eight
sleep ships to the usa canada and the uk
and again that's eightsleep.com
darkhorse
all right
our final sponsor this week is all form
a company that makes terrific custom
sofas we like them so much we have two
of them
what makes these sofa so terrific well
for a fraction of the cost of
traditional sofas you can customize size
layout fabric and color they do arm
chairs and love seats all the way up to
an eight seat sectional and you can
start small and buy more seats later on
without needing to get a whole new sofa
that's kind of an amazing thing it is
all form sofas are delivered directly to
your home free and fast and assembly is
easy it really is easy um also the
frames are incredibly rigid which you
wouldn't think was possible with a sofia
bolt together but it really is true
we started with one beautiful sectional
all-form sofa in whiskey leather it's
soft and supple and warm unlike a lot of
leather
we pile on it to watch movies some
evenings it looks gorgeous and is
incredibly inviting and comfortable a
rare combination we like it so much we
got a second one
also some listeners have asked if all
form sofas hold up to pets yes
anything smaller than a giraffe which to
be fair we haven't tried so maybe even
jerome's i guess actually we cannot
technically vouch on the giraffe front
but uh but everything we have tried it
with seems to work
um the leather that all form uses ish
no they're all fish ah
phylogenetics
they strike again i'm not surprised i
still wouldn't recommend fish
fishy fish yes um the leather that all
form uses is 20 thicker than typical
furniture leather and shows no wear
despite the fact that both cats and dog
lie on the couch many evenings and if
you prefer fabric all form fabrics are
three and a half times more durable than
the industry standard for heavy duty
fabrics so their fabrics are going to
hold up really well with pets also
finally they offer a forever warranty
literally forever
to find your perfect sofa go to
allform.com
darkhorse all form is offering 20 off
all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
darkhorse that's
a-l-o-f-o-r-m dot com slash dark horse
awesome all right
uh
maybe you
should start
all right unless you don't want to no no
i'm i'm uh i'm more than willing um
shall we start uh down the coved road
sure all right um
as much as we would love to be talking
about other things the number of
important developments uh in the land of
covet is so many and the amount that
rides not only on our ongoing developing
understanding of the way coveted covert
treatments work but also on our ability
to go back and figure out what we got
right and what we did not have right
in the past
now
this week this episode we are going to
talk about a result
that has recently
emerged
in which the
two major types of vaccines for covid
that is to say the adenovectored
vaccines and the mrna lipid nanoparticle
vectored vaccines
were assessed
with the measure of all-cause mortality
now that is an important thing to do and
the reason that it is an important thing
to do is that vaccines as we have
pointed out
hundreds of times maybe
are
basically an intervention into a series
of complex systems that series of
complex systems being
uh at least three layered you've got the
immune system which is complex system
inside of the critter that is the human
which is a complex system inside a
society of people in which a
pathogen
produces an epidemic so
all of these complex systems are going
to be affected by the various
interventions that we might
seek to deploy and their net effect is
what we ought to be interested in so
this recent study which is
technically not peer reviewed yet which
means that it was not handed to
anonymous reviewers and uh their
comments then delivered back to the
editors and the editors then deciding to
publish it but what has has been peer
reviewed in fact by uh martin kuldruff
and colleagues who looked through and
reported on this
zach do you want to show the website
that i sent you
so zach was going to bring up the
website in which
martin wrote about
these vaccines
in any case
so
as you and i heather have been talking
about from the beginning of the pandemic
peer review does not mean review by
peers peer review is a
i would argue a kind of jargon that
obscures the reality in which
peers are anonymously given a paper to
review by editors
and the amount of skullduggery that
flies beneath the radar
under this banner of peer review is
great and while some of us oppose this
kind of peer review
none of us who are worth our salt as
scientists oppose the idea of peers
reviewing work but we think it would be
much better done uh out in the open
transparently um
yes i'm wondering if before you show
this article by rotten koldorf um
you want to just show the actual yeah i
think i think we need to show the
pre-print which i also sent you on my
screen as well
that is absolutely the paper so either
way
um so here we have it uh
and called for those just listening
viewpoint randomized clinical trials of
covert 19 vaccines do adenovirus vector
vaccines have beneficial non-specific
effects and just as a reminder although
most most listeners and viewers will
already recognize this
we have two main classes of vaccines
that at least at least in the weird
world
have been widely available the mrna
vaccines produced by pfizer and moderna
two different ones and the adenovirus
factored vaccine is produced by johnson
johnson which is the only adenovirus
factor vaccine that's been
allowed in the united states and then
also astrazeneca
right and so actually maybe we should
just do a little of the biology here
both of these kinds of vaccines are
novel um and the
miracle which is their rapid production
in the aftermath
of covid also presents us with a problem
which is that we've got two platforms
essentially in which a vaccine can be
manufactured now apparently it can be
done very very quickly
that we know very little about we just
don't know what their effects are and
they work into
i would argue radically different ways
one of them takes an adenovirus and
basically implants a
antigen
or the message that produces an antigen
into this
this virus which is capable of infecting
human cells
and the other one takes an mrna which is
a message that a cell natively
transcribes and introduces it into the
cell as if it had just come from the
nucleus and the cell then faithfully
transcribes and actually translates this
message into a protein which is supposed
to then lodge in the cell surface but in
the mrna case instead of being delivered
by a virus which has evolved to infect
human cells it is delivered by
what's effectively a pseudovirus which
is a coat of these lipid nanoparticles
and these lipid nanoparticles lipid
means fat and the lipid nanoparticles
because they are
composed of fat and because the surface
of all cells is made up of fat based
membrane causes it to fuse light
dissolves like and basically lipid
nanomark particles touch a cell
the message is spilled in and then the
ribosomes in the in the cytoplasm
translate the uh the message into a
protein which then gets displayed on the
surface of the cell hopefully and the
immune system uh learns to recognize it
now you and i have talked at length
about the hazard of these new
technologies especially the lipid
nanoparticle one and the reason that the
lipid nanoparticle one has
caught our attention as something
particularly
concerning is that there is no
specificity whatsoever in
where these lipid nanoparticles deliver
their message they will deliver it to
whatever cells are most hospitable and
there is no reason to think that the
cells that are most usefully uh
delivered this message are the ones that
will pick it up it will circulate you
know in the
form that the manufacturers intended it
it's supposed to stay effectively in the
arm where it's injected and it's
supposed to be those cells uh presumably
the muscle cells would pick it up right
and a critical distinction being that
whereas with uh traditional vaccine
technology um of which there are also
two types and one of which is more
ancient than the other is as you'll talk
about but attenuated um but still live
uh versus dead vaccines um in both of
those cases the idea is we're gonna put
something in your body um the goal of
which is to get the attention of your
immune system so that it can learn how
to deal with such a pathogen if it runs
into it in its wild type
and in this case uh you
it is it is quite quite not that so it
is it is lacking specificity and uh the
expectation is not that in its in its
form in which it is injected the immune
system will recognize it although that
might also be the case but that it will
um move into cells and produce copies of
for the most part the spike protein and
um can i just
read a couple sentences from the
beginning of the introduction here of
this do you want to say who the authors
are um
yes the authors are uh i'm going to
butcher most of the names here christine
ben frederick schultz bookholter
sebastian nielsen
mahai nataya i apologize and peter abbey
um
this again is the pre-print called
randomized clinical trials of covet 19
vaccines do adenovirus vector vaccines
have beneficial non-specific effects or
are we just a couple sentences from the
intro and then sort of the conclusion
out of the abstract even though
that's not usually the order in which
one shares stuff
introduction within the current
understanding of vaccines it is logical
to assume that covet 19 vaccines reduce
overall mortality corresponding to the
number of code 19 deaths prevented
however there is now ample evidence that
vaccines can have broad heterologous
effects on the immune system these
effects can lead to additional
protection or increasing susceptibility
to unrelated infections or even other
non-infectious immune immune-mediated
diseases
therefore as it has now been established
in numerous studies vaccines may have
completely unexpected effects on overall
mortality different from what could be
anticipated based on the protection
against the vaccine-targeted disease
that is an excellent proceed right there
of
uh basically the argument that then the
first author on the paper christine ben
makes in an interview with unheard that
you will also talk about the cheat that
she did this week for why unlike what
was done for instance in the trials that
pfizer ran
we should not be focusing on only
on
effect on that disease but overall
mortality all cause mortality to use the
term of art right so with regard and and
frankly it's easier it's easier to look
at all cars brutality because you don't
have to end up dithering as and
dithering minimizes the importance of
this but as many of us have have been
trying to figure out these last two
years and for many people many for much
longer than that like well you know in
the case of kovid it's only the last two
years two plus now um you know did she
die of covet or with covet and because
um you know especially now with omicron
being so highly transmissible and so
many people have had it or still have
evidence of it circulating um there are
it is quite clear quite a number of um
you know
sometimes presumably unintentional
sometimes absolutely intentional messing
with the numbers such that all of these
deaths that are attributed to kovid are
not actually deaths that happened
because of covin but deaths that
happened while the person also was
infected with kobe you know people who
entered hospital for entirely other
reasons were then tested found to have
cove and died for those entirely other
reasons and were listed as having died
of covet so all of that um all of that
problem is avoided if you focus on all
cosmetic all-cause mortality in those
people who got
say mrna vaccines versus adenovirus
vaccines and that's the comparison being
made here not to unvaccinated people
um you know was all cosmetic or that's
not no no no it's not it's not exactly
right so um in these three groups is all
cause mortality um
you know better or better or worse and
uh the abstract uh reveals here can we
can we hold off can we lay a little more
groundwork okay then he shouldn't be
showing the screen yeah i mean
it's not a secret but
first of all this comes in the context
right and you hinted at that context but
i think that context
you have to understand it in order to
see
why a study like this is likely to tell
you something really important that you
might not know so
dr ben
talks about prior work which has
revealed a pattern i believe that
she and her team studied 10 vaccines
that are just part of the standard
schedule of vaccines for children
and the pattern that they found
was that the live attenuated virus
vaccines
tended to increase longevity they
decreased all cause mortality and the
all-cause mortality decrease could not
be attributed to the target disease
entirely itself could not entirely be
attributed to that right so for example
uh in the case of the measles vaccine
there was a benefit in the reduction of
measles which did account for some
fraction of the reduction in overall
loss of life but it didn't account for
all of it not even close
so the point is there are non-specific
effects of these vaccines and we don't
entirely understand what they come from
one could imagine for example this is
one plausible example
that cross-reactivity because viruses
are related to each other being
vaccinated against one virus might
create immunity to another virus that
had similar
uh surface structure and which maybe
we're not as familiar we don't have a
name yet we certainly don't have a
vaccine but now you've got right um some
some baseline immunity to something that
the medical establishment isn't formally
looking out for right and it doesn't
have to be that direct it could also be
that because the immune system exerts a
selective pressure on the viruses
themselves viruses may come that aren't
closely related may come to resemble
each other because what they're doing is
they are evolving to be invisible to the
immune system and so cross-reactivity
doesn't even require that the viruses
be related but in any case the basic
point is if you look at the attenuated
virus vaccines
what you see is an all-cause mortality
benefit you get the exact opposite when
you look at the uh killed virus vaccine
so again these are the two broad types
of vaccines that existed before you know
a couple years ago right
um now and what's an example of a killed
virus vaccine that we will
most of us have gotten i am not going to
take well let's see if we can do i just
don't i we can i don't use it from the
fact of needing
boosters um
but in any case i'm not i'm not going to
guess but uh the
the point is when
people who are dark horse listeners will
have heard the following logic discussed
by us here before
if you have an attenuated virus a live
virus vaccine
it do you have an answer
um you know this is just
uh
this is off of a site called passport
health global so i'm not going to vouch
for it beyond that but some attenuated
live virus vaccines include mmr as you
said yellow fever oral polio vaccination
and oral typhoid
and some dead vaccines include um
uh they say polio here and they they're
gonna mean not oral um cholera uh which
all i mean collar is a crap vaccine
long before any of these legs just got
really low efficacy influenza hep a and
typhoid and again it's the non-oral
typhoid
so um
the
the logic works something like this
when you get an attenuated virus vaccine
that is a living vaccine that is a
weakened form it doesn't make you sick
and hopefully it can't transmit from one
person to another right all bets are off
if something figures out how to jump
from one individual to another but if a
attenuated virus that can infect cells
enough to give you a very mild infection
hopefully one that you can't even detect
you've gotten anything maybe you've got
you know your arm has a slight fever or
something like that for a day this sort
of thing yeah yeah
that because it is an infection right
causes the immune system have the right
reaction right they work very well for
this reason they're also a little scary
for this reason because you're dealing
with an organism that
has heredity and therefore could evolve
it doesn't evolve very well if it
doesn't move from one person to the next
but as soon as
that trick gets introduced
it's a very different thing but in the
case of a killed virus
or a antigen from a killed virus a piece
of a virus that you're delivering to the
immune system
the immune system
may spot it because it's foreign but it
doesn't look like an infection and so
the reaction is often very weak
so two things are true one
you may get more than one vaccination in
order to introduce the same antigen
multiple times which sort of simulates
an infection and two trigger is the goal
here unlike in much of social space now
like you're trying to trigger your
immune system
what
but then the other thing the thing that
you and i have talked about hey wait a
minute what the heck is this technology
and whoever said that was safe is the
adjuvants and the adjuvants are
basically
immune irritants
immune irritants that cause the immune
system to react like there's an
infection which then raises all kinds of
questions about how good are they at
spotting the thing that the vaccine
manufacturer wants them to react to
versus the stuff that was involved in
the food that you ate
or your own tissues right in other words
annoying your immune system with an
adjuvant is basically an invitation to
the
inappropriate
activity of the immune system either in
the form of allergies or autoimmunity
and so anyway what uh dr ben reveals in
her in her interview
about this paper which is narrower is
that in this prior work the the the
answer came out pretty clear the
dead virus or pieces of virus the
antigen based uh adjuvant containing
vaccines reduced all redu uh reduced
longevity increased all-cause mortality
and the live virus
vaccines
decreased all-cause mortality so so just
um
are
live also known as attenuated
virus vaccines inherently adjuvant free
do you know do you know the answer to
this okay i i know that that's the
general pattern it may be a hundred
percent but
in any case so this they have all sorts
of things going for them
right yeah so
and i mean this sorry but this just
reminds me and this is what we've been
saying from the beginning of cobit and
the prospect of vaccines like oh goody
cool vaccines vaccines are one of
broadly speaking the three major
successes of western medicine
antibiotics and surgery being the other
two
and oh by the way
just because we call it a vaccine
doesn't mean it's awesome
and especially if we are in an
environment in which people are willing
to play all sorts of games with words
and slot anything over into vaccine
space oh and at the same time start
redefining what vaccine means and what
vaccination means and what anti-vaxxer
means well
there's just no ability to communicate
anything clearly and so
really it shouldn't be necessary for all
sorts of people who aren't inherently
biologists or don't want to be paying
attention this sort of thing to keep
track of all the different types of
things that are currently being called
vaccines but for those of us who are
dealing with both you know as everyone
is a global
crisis
some of which is based in health and
some of which is based in politics
and are trying to be clear
and also don't simply have the position
either
that no vaccines are good i want to stay
away from all of them or anything that
you choose to call a vaccine is good and
therefore shoot me up
that vast middle ground
is actually the scientifically rigorous
place to be and therefore we feel the
need to to talk talk through why both
the mrna and the adenovirus vectored
vaccines that were introduced i think
the adenovirus affected vaccines were
also introduced with covet or did they
yeah pre-exist copy uh i'm not i can't
say what's been done in other creatures
but for humans first time i believe this
is right too and certainly for mrna i
mean they were they were trying some
stuff but it wasn't working
um but with regard to the two and i you
know i don't know for missing other
categories but so far we've talked about
four sort of categories of vaccines here
today and the two
categories of vaccines that pre-existed
um
that existed five years ago
being dead or parts of virus uh viruses
or you know antigen uh you call them
antigen vaccines this is and i'm
i'm not sure i've heard that but it
makes sense versus live also known as
attenuated vaccines of all of these
there is one and only one
and it is the original one right is the
original formulation of vaccines i
believe right
the attenuated or live vaccines
that actually appear
given what dr ben's past research has
indicated
and what frankly well more than a
century of research has indicated to
reduce all-cause mortality and those who
receive them right now um
i will say
the work on the
live
attenuated versus the killed virus
vaccines and their relatives i didn't
know that work existed i didn't know
that anybody had done all cause
mortality work and so it's not purely
independent but i will point out
this is reflective of exactly the logic
that you and i worked our way towards we
figured this out this is what we
predicted and there's one aspect of this
that i didn't predict
um
which is worth pointing out too because
the question is how good is the model
yeah right i didn't predict uh a
all-cause mortality benefit from
generalized administration of um
uh of a
live
virus vaccine okay
i that that's a little surprising to me
right that goes beyond that goes beyond
that target disease yeah so and that
wasn't included to what you said so
there's all-cause mortality that may
increase
because the benefit against that disease
is so high yes but all-cause mortality
that is not fully explicable by the
benefit of fighting the target disease
right whereas terrific whereas the
hey there are going to be other effects
you're intervening in a layered series
of complex systems with uh a therapy
that's going to have multiple impacts
almost all of them negative in the case
of the killed virus adjuvant vaccines
that we did say right that did seem very
likely
um and turns out to be turns out to be
true
the conclusion of this paper which we
should probably get to now is equally
interesting in this regard yeah so just
reading from the paper and you can show
my screen if you like sec this is just
this is just from the abstract of the
paper
where though here we go
the
the
sorry i lost track so i was going to
read this earlier and i'm not sure now
which part of this to read because
there's a lot of numbers that are just
going to drag on
um the short version
i'm not sure which of this is the most
relevant to read so
um we can put up uh we can put up from
the web page the martin koldruff uh zach
could you give me my screen back so i
can see my notes that would be terrific
here
um
and yeah put that back up thank you
scroll down to there's a little uh
what is the term for that uh matrix
there
which i can't read at this distance but
i can kind of barely read it um
nonetheless
can you put it on the
okay
so
what we have here
so first of all there are constraints
that's just because we said we were
going to stay okay
the
two types of mrna vaccines
um it's the two types of covet vaccines
one of them now the two types of mria
vaccines in the second row here
um it's under the relative risk column
that we're looking at have
the the all-cause mortality is higher
than among those who were unvaccinated
as i believe the comparison here it's
1.03 where one is the baseline rate
whereas for the adenovirus factor
vaccines of which there are also two
types
j and j and astrazeneca the relative
risk
also you know which is sort of a
stand-in for all-cause mortality is 0.37
which is to say
the adenovirus factor vaccines
reduce
all-cause mortality
uh quite substantially actually and the
mrna vaccines do not in fact um you know
the numbers are so close as to
effectively make it make it equal um
although in fact it's
slightly higher well there are certain
nuances we have to add in order to
understand what these numbers mean but
the basic pattern is the adenovector the
adenovirus vectored vaccines
substantially reduced all-cause
mortality as one would hope from any
good vaccine
and
the mrna vaccines the lipid nanoparticle
vectored vaccines very slightly and
maybe not importantly increased
all-cause mortality
so
and i should point out
in dr ben's interview which i suggest
everybody look at on unheard we will
provide a link to it
she is very clear on the fact that both
types of vaccine appeared to reduce
covid significantly
so to the extent that the mrna and mrna
vaccines have actually increased the
amount of mortality
right what it says is that they are
doing some kind of harm that more than
compensates for the benefit that people
got from the reduction in the amount of
covet now
i am cautious about this whole realm
because the studies that were being
looked at were studies that were done by
the manufacturers
um and so the question is how
scrupulous were the manufacturers and a
lot of the work suggests maybe not so
scrupulous so was there a coveted
benefit probably but we don't really
know because there's lots of reason to
wonder what happened here but the point
is the all-cause mortality number
is much harder to game right people
either died or they didn't and they were
either in the placebo group or the
treatment group and exactly the point is
those numbers are actually with
short of outright fraud those numbers
allow you to do this kind of analysis
and they suggest that there is a massive
difference between the adenovirus
vectored vaccines and the mrna vaccines
furthermore actually hadn't occurred to
me until just now as you were talking
you know what a vaccine is supposed to
do and what these vaccines particularly
do has been changing like they have just
been changing our expectations about
what we should demand of vaccines from
from the moment that we first had
accident or hearing about them and then
had access to them through now and
a number of us are you know throwing up
the alarm over this but for the most
part people are like oh well they never
said it would reduce death it's just
supposed to reduce um you know symptoms
and make it you know less bad for you
which of course is not true that is not
nothing they ever said however
this suggests it doesn't matter so as
much as we have been talking for
uh you know a very long time
about uh focusing only on mortality with
regard to covid is too narrow a scope
that long covet is is real and there's a
lot of things that might be passing
under long covert that aren't that and
might be vaccine effects and this that
and the other but you know there is real
stuff there and this of course being a
franken virus we don't know we cannot
predict with as much
specificity or reliability what it's
going to do in the future because it
didn't evolve in a cave in bats right
and you know it evolved through serial
passage
um research in a in a lab maybe with
ferrets
so you know that changes expectations
about what to predict next but
regardless regardless of what other
benefits it may or may not be providing
if the mortality is the same ish
uh then that is the bottom line
well okay
the mortality is
the same as as if you were not
vaccinated against
covet with these vaccines at all right
so in principle i agree that almost
everything ought to show up in the
all-cause mortality data with the caveat
that we need longer time well that's
that's where i'm going next yeah part of
the problem here right is
that one of the things that is most
troubling about the way and there are
many troubling things about the way the
manufacturers ran their tests but one of
the things that is most troubling
is that at the point that they had early
numbers that they claimed said that
these things were spectacularly
effective
at preventing covid and very very safe
what they did is they vaccinated their
control group right now
were you
forget what these people actually were
up to
were you a corrupt
pharmaceutical manufacturer interested
in hiding harms done by your vaccines
vaccinating your control group is what
you would do in order to obscure that so
not saying that that's why this was done
but i am saying that basically there is
a
predictable loophole in the logic of
science as it is applied to clinical
trials and the loophole comes in the
form of
should you be in the lucky position of
discovering a treatment that is so
effective and so safe that everybody
should want it then you are morally
obligated to treat your controls because
denying it to them would be unfair right
now
given that we know that that's the way
the
moral rules of
clinical trials work shooting for that
outcome in other words this is a
perverse incentive if only we can get to
the place where these things look super
safe and super effective then we get to
vaccinate our controls then anything
that
isn't safe about it will disappear
right which then of course fits with
the bizarre fervor to vaccinate every
damn person
right which also eliminates the natural
control group that comes from the fact
that a lot of us are you know go slow
you're intervening in a complex system
hesitant here so in any case the point
is this study this study done by dr ben
and her colleagues is compromised by
their own analysis by the fact that the
data they were working from has a very
short time horizon because of the way it
was collected and then stopped being
collected because the control group
disappears compromised through no fault
of their own and there's nothing they
can do about it right and in fact the
data do not exist what they've said is
that actually we should be testing these
things in a way that we can uh we can
compare them directly and in fact
we couldn't do that here and that's
unfortunate but the other point that i
want to make is that what that means is
that
there are two problems with the
numbers that we have for all cause
mortality here
one of them is that we don't really know
all cause mortality because what you
should be doing is tracking the
treatment group and the control group
two years out
five years out 10 years
20 years
and then you know ideally what you'd
want to know
is the ultimate longevity of the people
who did and did not get this
treatment and then we could say
something about what its net effect was
using mortality as a proxy for
good and bad health effects but we can't
do that here because a it hasn't been
very long so even if they had not
vaccinated the control group and these
numbers were continuing to inform us it
still hasn't been very long but it's way
worse than that because they rushed
these things to market having vaccinated
the control group which robs us of the
ability to say anything about
effects even a couple of years out yeah
um so that that is a significant factor
so my point is
uh 1.03 is just barely over one right
it's probably meaningless in terms of it
having increased the risk of death
however
you know what that doesn't contain it
doesn't contain anything about uh
the
increase in the rate of cancer that some
people believe derives
uh from the mrna vaccines right so
um
the point is let's say that cancer is
one of the outgrowths that these things
are carcinogenic in some way well then
the point is all of that increase in uh
mortality will be absent from this study
and will show up later and so um so the
point is 1.03
uh
isn't
terribly bad it is conspicuous in the
following way now here this is sorry
that this is so complicated but um but i
think it's important to think of it this
way
okay you've got a number in which the
amount of mortality with the mrna
vaccines was slightly elevated over the
amount of mortality in people who didn't
get them but were otherwise matched
right so close effectively effectively
the same right
however
what that means to the extent that these
vaccines appear to provide a benefit
from covid
that means that they did harm of some
other kind like cardiovascular and
here's the point
if you knew that if the work had been
done well right and you knew okay
these vaccines create
a benefit in terms of covid and
mortality downstream from it and they
create a harm by inducing other
pathologies the absolutely obvious thing
to do
is to not administer them to everybody
right those who's at risk comes
primarily from covid might warrant the
thing and those who have very low risk
from covid would should be protected
from them you know at the very least
given the other vaccine right so the in
the fact that we are not in a position
to say look
the thing has an effect on covet as
predicted as far as we know right maybe
not but it seems to have some benefit
for covid it has some cost that nobody
who isn't at risk from kovid should be
exposed to and the all-cause mortality
could be driven way down by not
vaccinating people who get no benefit on
the covet side and have only risk from
the let's say cardiovascular side right
that's the obvious thing to do
and the fact that you know we're playing
some stupid game where the idea is
vaccines good were they good for people
let's give them to everyone right
i'm sorry that's just not the way right
now and let's
not even pretend to do science and and
definitely get rid of the control group
definitely get right yeah and i do want
to come back uh full circle actually on
something that you were going to talk
about um before we really introduced all
of this suck if you scroll i do remember
this piece now i think it came out a
couple weeks ago if you scroll to the
bottom of what you've got on our screen
and show the audience as well the bottom
of this
article yeah we'll go up a little bit so
okay
um
go down a little bit more so i have it
on my screen now okay now up a little
bit
uh here we go
um some may criticize the danish study
for not yet being peer reviewed but it
has been it was peer reviewed by me and
several colleagues and all of us have
decades of experience with these types
of studies that has not yet been peer
reviewed by anonymous journal or viewers
is inconsequential
that is exactly the same argument that
we made about vaccines right you know
peer review is this idea
that may or may not be the best way to
go about actually assessing whether or
not a scientific result uh is likely to
be
remarkable replicable and rigorous uh
and um and therefore the result is
likely to stand for a while uh what is
what is not true is that invoking peer
review therefore makes you
scientifically literate or uh indicates
that the thing that was peer-reviewed is
therefore definitely true
same thing for vaccines right just
because the concept
has in its birth something awesome about
it does not mean that the way it is
currently being used either has a uh
any relationship with that origin or
that um or that it is being used
appropriately by the people saying it so
i thought this was just just brilliant
um you know this is
again martin calder saying yeah people
are gonna people people who don't know
what they're talking about
will say this research is just a
pre-print it's not peer-reviewed
therefore i can ignore it and he's
saying you know what
i'm as good an arbiter as any and he
doesn't say it but i will go ahead and
say like he's probably a much better
arbiter than almost everyone if not
anyone else he's peer-reviewed it he's
assessed the research uh he's better at
it than we are we don't do this research
we're we're merely sort of you know
biologists in in not even a particularly
adjacent field going like okay we can
read science and we can assess this and
we can also read other scientists who
are assessing it going like i assessed
it that's what peer review is
therefore um you know not to say that
there are errors and he actually goes
through
sort of the weaknesses and he doesn't
point to the authors of the bend study
at all he says given the data they were
working with which is the fault of the
trials done by you know the the
pharmaceutical companies who did them
given the day they were working with
they did as bang up a job as you could
possibly expect right and i want to make
clear though
um you're right he is definitely in a
better position to peer review this
because this is his field right right
what we did was
what our job is right we went through
the evolutionary logic and i've pointed
to the place that i think we missed
something uh that turns out to be true
and clear right the potential benefit
for
vaccination with
live virus vaccines
you have heard us say
actually there's a huge schedule of
vaccines that people get what are the
chances that it's all going to be good
right um so the question is and you know
hey it turns out to be a much stronger
signal than we might have even expected
but it goes in the direction that we
point it out and it's clarifying and
simplifying right it's not just oh i
have to somehow figure out i have to
know it's like actually we are presented
here by ben's former research
uh
given a choice um
especially so was it i think it was
polio and typhoid and that both have an
oral version and a non-oral version and
one of them is live attenuated and one
of them is adjuvant rich you know dead
and you know go with the live attenuated
right when given a choice okay so our
model worked well there we figured out a
pattern and the pattern is stronger than
even i would have guessed okay that's
good
that's you know
potentially a little compromised because
that work existed before we did our
logic so it's impossible to know whether
we were in some way informed by it
although
certainly never encountered the work
until now however on the front of the
current the coveted vaccines right you
and i also at length went through the
logic here and what we came up with
was
uh we are
concerned about the hazard of both of
these technologies but if we had to get
one it would be the adenovector one why
did a virus vector the adenovirus vector
why because
a
one
dose which actually should have been a
clue to us about the effectiveness of it
alerting the immune system but um
the adenovector virus the adenovirus
vectored
vaccine is one dose and the lipid
nanoparticles are clearly concerning
with respect to
their ability to get into cells and then
the likelihood of them uh causing the
attack of those cells by the immune
system which would surely read the cells
that were making the spike protein as
virally infected which might be true of
the adeno vector the adenovirus vectored
vaccines too but it's not likely to be a
random distribution which could land in
your heart or some other circulatory
tissue so
i don't know these numbers suggest
a net benefit to the adenovic virus
vectored vaccines
whereas no benefit to the others at a
net level we don't know how that looks
over the long term it's still possible
that the
adenovirus vectored vaccines
are net negative if you look over a
longer time horizon however we did get
the logic
right about
which one to bet on from the point of
view of reducing the risks of
intervening in a complex system in a new
and uh unknown
way and so in any case
um i think it reflects well on what we
were doing and given the amount of crap
we've taken over uh what we were doing
uh those who have given us that crap i
think uh are now have the burden of
explaining how it is that we guessed
these things if we weren't
actually doing the logic correctly right
uh i would i would have to agree with
that
shall we
move to another topic
slightly all right
um
you
the audience will not be surprised to
hear us advocating that you should get
yourself outside
get outside we have been saying from the
very beginning we have this is this is
you know this has been one of our drum
beats one of our mantras from long
before we were here before you talking
about any of this
and some of that is for reasons that we
can point to and some of it is for
reasons that we don't exactly point to
but allude to in many ways in for
instance hunter-gatherer's guide to the
21st century in which we say
you know what
uh there are things that humans have
been doing for depending on exactly what
system you're talking about and how long
you want to count thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands you know
billions of years depending right
and some of those things we know uh some
of the pieces parts of what it is the
benefits are
but some of them
are likely to bring with them benefits
that actually we can't we don't yet
fully know
we maybe can't even yet ever know
and if we try to disassociate the
benefits from the package in which they
have historically come to us
we may in fact
negate or even reverse the benefits
so getting outside i think uh turns out
to be one of these so i'm going to set
this up in sort of a little um somewhat
counter counter-intuitive way because it
appears at first to maybe run counter to
some things that we've talked about but
i think ultimately it doesn't
so we will link to a youtube video on
the youtube channel medcram called the
vitamin d paradox in cobit 19 and why it
predicts but doesn't always protect now
we of course have talked a lot about the
benefits of vitamin d um brett did an
excellent uh conversation with two
one preeminent vitamin d researcher and
someone who's a little bit more recently
to the game but you know they just they
had a ton of information and we've also
talked with them
and i've written up a fairly long thing
on my substance about the benefits of
vitamin d and why
unlike actually what we wrote in our
book
this is one of the few cases where we
think actually supplementation that you
know taking the little the peace and and
taking it into your body that way will
be beneficial uh and you know one of the
reasons that we argue
for our ch our change in opinion
is that unlike almost all of the other
things that you might supplement your
diet with those are things that you
normally could be getting from a whole
food nutrient dense closer to you know
its origin diet whereas vitamin d for
the vast majority of humans for the vast
majority of our history have gotten most
of our vitamin d from synthesizing it
through the skin from the sun
i'll add one thing yes i think we have
been perfectly consistent and i hope
clear every time we have discussed it
that even though we have argued in favor
of supplementation as something that is
quite safe and potentially useful and
for those of us who live in the
temperate zones very likely uh
beneficial because we tend to be
deficient strongly tend to be division
we have never once argued that you
wouldn't be better off getting this
through photosynthesis in the sun right
right so we've been clear about that the
basic point is failing getting enough of
it from the sun supplementation is
likely to be valuable that's right
uh so
uh
we have for instance i'm gonna just
say i'm gonna ask you to quickly show a
couple of things on my screen but but um
then kind of go off of them quickly we
have a paper that finds
here
pre-infection
25 hydroxy vitamin d3 levels in
association with severity of covid19
illness
if i may have my screen back thanks i'm
sorry i didn't get to printing
everything out this week so i don't have
a backup
which finds that
so that first paper finds that people
with low vitamin d levels before illness
are more likely to have bad covert
outcomes okay
we have a uh
rct uh here a a randomized uh control
trial the current randomized clinical
trial that finds here's the title
efficacy and safety of vitamin d
supplementation to prevent covert 19 and
frontline healthcare workers and they
find that yes there is there is a
benefit to that
and um however we have another rct which
is the one the medcram video um shows uh
and talks about
which is called here um
zach you can show my screen just briefly
this is a it's a pre-print it doesn't
look the same vitamin d supplements for
prevention of cover 19 or other acute
respiratory infections a phase iii
randomized control trial
and what they find surprisingly is
conclusions of the abstract among adults
with a high baseline prevalence of
vitamin d insufficiency
implementation of a test and treat
approach to vitamin d replacement did
not reduce risk of all-cause
ari which it's going to be like acute
respiratory infection or copenhagen they
found that vitamin d baseline vitamin d
levels increased but that
that
that responses to other acute
respiratory infections or copper 19 were
not improved so that runs counter uh to
the previous um rct
uh that i showed
and um you know there's there's a lot of
you know maybe there are other
contributing factors
maybe the fact that it wasn't very high
dosage vitamin d it was in like i don't
remember it's like 3 200 ius per day
they didn't give a bolus dose as dr
benskin has suggested is important
although the rct that did find a benefit
and the mexican healthcare workers also
didn't use a bolus dose there are a lot
of factors here right
um
but
it does seem like there may be something
additional going on and here i just want
to show
and actually zach if you could put up
that first screenshot that i sent you so
i've just got
um
yep so that the files are numbered but
they should have come in in the numbered
order
and here we go
this is from again this medcram video
that i will link to as well
in which the um the guy talking his name
i've forgotten i apologize
says okay being outside versus inside
has more than one effect
it's not just about uv and of course
it's the uv um light
that converts that basically
photosynthesizes although i'm always
nervous about using that term with
humans but the photosynthesizes into
vitamin d in the skin
in in humans so yes we have if you're
outside you have higher uv and then you
have more production of vitamin d
and
and that is true
also however when you're outside you
have higher levels of near infrared
radiation exposure and what that causes
and i'm going to explain a little bit
more about this although i'm not going
to go into all of the all of the kind of
frankly exciting stuff that i've been
learning in the last 24 hours about this
um higher levels of intracellular
melatonin that's intracellular melatonin
which is different from the circulating
melatonin produced by the pineal gland
which is the the thing that we think of
when we think of melatonin when we think
of melatonin we think of it being
like the nighttime hormone
and it's circulating it's produced by
the pineal gland intracellular melatonin
is produced by mitochondria
and actually appears to mitigate and uh
modulate a lot of things about health
including respiration and metabolism and
homeostasis all right so i just want to
go evolutionary biologist here on this a
little bit
not surprising to see
the same molecule show up in two
radically different mechanisms because
basically the point is it's a signal
molecule and it works at a distance and
it also works uh in close proximity and
yes
the
physiology of the body can simply
you wouldn't expect it to come up with a
whole new signal because the point is
the signal has already evolved and it
can be repurposed and this is something
that actually it's not infrequent to see
this kind of thing in fact
neurotransmitters
often
work on various different systems
and then this is in fact yet another
example of how our reduction is thinking
like oh oh we figured out melatonin we
got it we know what it's for
okay i think we are correct that we know
one of the things that it it is for and
even that language makes me nervous but
you know apparent the melatonin that is
produced by the pineal gland that ends
up circulating does appear to be four in
quotes um
helping to modulate circadian rhythms
and sleep weight patterns
but melatonin the molecule
when produced intracellularly by the
mitochondria and does not circulate
appears to be about cleaning up anti
like about about dealing
with antioxidants and basically involved
in a lot of of cellular health uh that
it's the same it's the same molecule
it's in a different place it's produced
in a different way under different
circumstances and it's doing a different
job and both of those jobs are necessary
for us but they're not the same job so
it cleans up
basically free radicals it clean that is
at least that is one of the things that
we now understand and by we i mean these
researchers who have not this is not
very old research yeah this is pretty
new like we've we the scientific
community has understood melatonin as
like the sleep molecule
um circulating um helps in train wake
sleep cycles for a pretty long time and
i don't know if by long time i mean
decades or closing in on a century
but this other
function of melatonin is is newer to us
the scientific community and
humanity at large so i will just throw
into the mix here that one of the
those who have dared to generate
treatment early treatment protocols for
covid have had melatonin on the list and
it has been a head scratcher for me why
why would this be and in fact i think
they're going to have its place as i was
going yup in a previous live stream i
think we talked about the question of
whether or not that is an effect of the
molecule or it is an effect of the
benefit of sleep which is well
understood to be
an important contributor to and is it
related that one of the main symptoms of
covid is deep fatigue
i don't know i don't i you know i don't
know which of these things might be
connected or not but it does seem like
there are a number of connections here
that's really interesting right also
raises interesting
welcome to complex system style
questions about so just like for like
i'm actually this is brand new to me but
it's even brand or new to brett like
bret this is the first time i've i told
you i want to talk about this and i'm
not going to give you the
right i'm not going to tell you what it
says so this is brand new to you right
now brand new so the question then uh
is well a you there's certain things we
know now you might intuit from your own
experience but we know now uh from
scientific work that actually there are
certain elements of repair that require
you to be
dormant right right so that
you know the advice to you know take
lots of fluids and get sleep is about
more than just you know not having
better advice to give you but
it provides an opportunity to do things
and thereby you know not sleeping denies
your body the opportunity to do things
increases the risk of
negative health impacts but the question
i guess is if you were you know if you
had a hormone like like uh melatonin
that triggered sleep and there were some
aspect of
oxidant control that was better deployed
during sleep in other words if there are
you know a trade-off between you know
what your body prioritizes when awake
and therefore you know well so one one
of the things that i'm i'm learning and
this is again new to me even newer to
you but new new to me is that
it is now proposed and there is some
research evidence to support this that
um basically
near-infrared radiation
uh triggers the intracellular production
of melatonin by uh by mitochondria and
it tends to produce an excess which is
then held in reserve for those moments
when there's not enough
and uh and
uh that would be consistent uh
potentially with what what you're
talking about um it would also be let's
see i was just going to go one other
place but actually uh this may prompt me
to remember the thing i was just going
to say if you could show that second
screenshot zach which should just be the
next one that i sent you which relates
to a decrease in full sunlight exposure
in humans from 1800 to the present day
so this this is extraordinary and this
is actually
borrowed you can for those of you
watching you see at the bottom the
zimmermann and writer paper 2019 which
i'm going to read to you a little bit
from
but this this screenshot is from the
medcram video and actually can you show
that on our smaller screen zach so i can
see it although i obviously oh no it's
okay i'll just pull it up if i if i can
find it but i need to
talk for a moment here while i find this
thing because it's going to take me a
while
um
no wrong one
um
yeah there we go okay so let me just
find my
notes again
um
we have and i'll just walk walk us
through it for those listening and even
for those watching
we have um
via the the two the blue and the red
blue is visible spectrum light and red
is near infrared spectrum light and one
oh i know one of the things uh that i
learned today is
that near infrared spectrum
light
a goes through clothes
and is highly reflective off of foliage
so even if you're dressed and in shade
if you are outside you are still getting
near infrared spectrum light if the sun
is up okay so this is this is not true
for uv for the most part right so what
we have done as humans is focused on
that which we can see right that which
we can sense and that of course is
defined exactly as the visible spectrum
we named it it's the visible spectrum
for us it's of course not the same part
of the spectrum that's visible for bees
and snakes and other things
but the visible spectrum is that which
we can see directly
infrared being off one side ultraviolet
being off the other side of it
both all of it though the
electromagnetic
spectrum that we receive from the sun
is
um brings value that we have only begun
to
perceive so in 1800
uh we were getting um i don't know
that's this there's no
you know there's no y axis on this but
you know two and a half times as much uh
near infrared
uh light as visible light because we
were out about 50 outside and we were
also getting it from campfires so
campfires give you near infrared as well
isn't that beautiful isn't that a lovely
a lovely little thing for us you like to
talk about campfire both literal and
metaphorical metaphorical campfire
doesn't provide you um infrared light
but but literal campfires do
by 1950 actually
it can make you hot under the collar
not the same thing though
really not
so by 1950
uh the
the visible spectrum light that humans
and you know presumably we're talking
about weird humans you know western
educated industrialized rich democratic
et cetera
we're getting was lower um
but also so was the near infrared light
on account of
uh we had we had light bulbs which we
didn't have in 1800 but they're 100
incandescent which do emit in near
infrared
and we were using plain glass windows in
our windows which let 25 or so of the
near infrared through and oh no that's
actually that's supposed to be on a
different line playing less windows
which let a certain amount i don't
remember the percentage of the near
infrared through and the estimators were
spending about 25 of our time outdoors
by 1990 we've begun to move into
fluorescent fluorescent does not emit
near-infrared
and we still got plain glass windows
which are letting some of the infrared
through and we're spending less time
outdoors
and by
the present time we've got
100 percent
visible only light bulbs with leds and
oleds and compact fluorescents so
incandesce we're phasing out
incandescents even though everyone knows
they feel better with incandescent
lights right and part of why they feel
better
i'm going to pause it and i'm sure this
is partially true is that because they
are emitting this near-infrared light
which we are completely deficient in we
now have low e glass windows which are
great if what your priority is is to
decrease energy loss and therefore
decrease your energy bills and you know
decrease how much we need to rely on
whatever your energy source is
but if energy cost is the only priority
and uh and it's measurable you can
measure how much energy loss there is
and no one has yet figured out as we
hadn't until recently this thing and who
knows how many other things we haven't
figured out how human health will suffer
as a result of low e-windows what you've
done with the low e windows is you've
also reduced the near infrared light
that's getting through them to zero and
we're spending this estimate is roughly
seven percent of our time outdoors our
near infrared light
exposure
is staggeringly low
and if we go outside even if we're
closed even if we're under some cover we
are getting near infrared light and so
at some level you know this this i'm
going to continue to go on but
get outside like a get outside and don't
assume that the vitamin d supplement
which yes especially in northern
temperate winters and southern temperate
winters the opposite time of year um are
likely to be helpful but it's not
the only thing that you should be doing
all right that's fine is your mind like
mind is
um
i will say that one
you know if we keep saying uh near
infrared
then
we sort of obscure what's actually
happening here which is that we are
getting more and more efficient yeah the
point is what you mean our technology in
terms of our built environment yes what
i mean is
you think just like with with milk right
what is breast milk it's food hey we can
replace food with other food yeah well
what if it's food vaccines or vaccines
peer review is peer review
right exactly and so the point is the
joke
the joke all of us who have you know
worked on anything with a limited energy
budget the joke is that uh a an
incandescent bulb is a heater that
happens to put out some light right
right it's terrifically wasteful yeah um
and so it's like oh ow why like why did
i right just try to unscrew a bulb that
was just on
try that with an led it's fine well leds
are somewhat you know cfls are
first of all i should say as you know
i've been ranting about cfls for decades
these things were never green they are
efficient but they were never green and
they were never healthy yeah um they
were a disaster and the idea that people
have had these things in their homes and
been breaking them and releasing mercury
and not realizing how much mercury they
just put into their environment it's
insane right that was a con um leds are
way better because i mean also i mean
this is another this is branding like oh
call it green you'll get a lot of people
to buy it's like actually there are a
lot of us who really do give a damn who
really do care and are not buying your
you know your like tokenism of like if
we call it green you're gonna buy it
because we know you're that much of a
sucker well actually this goes to uh one
of your themes
you know the tyranny of metrics thing
which is to the extent that we can
measure something like how much coal has
to be burned at the plant in order to
make this light bulb put up enough light
to do your work the answer is yes cfl is
pretty good right if you were going to
do the equivalent of the all-cause
mortality thing it's a freaking disaster
right it misinforms your pineal gland it
puts mercury in the environment all over
the goddamn place
it messes up your sleep cycles it's it's
a disaster and as it turns out it
reduces your
access further to near-infrared which is
uh important for dealing with the
oxidants that you are generating because
you get a crap diet and a bad lifestyle
which is also fed to you by uh you know
we moderns are living the greatest life
imaginable it's like in some ways yes
but that doesn't mean we have to buy
every every solution that is handed to
us because many of them are bad and some
of them are bad and we don't know why
yet but if we are thinking
not sure about that one
maybe trust your instinct and think on
it more right right so i'm curious about
all kinds of net impacts here right so
i'm i'm particularly struck i did not
see coming the low e window
thing yeah the low e window thing which
maybe i don't understand something about
this but my guess is it's going to work
in the opposite direction based on
whether you're primarily
losing energy to a hot outside
environment or a cold outside
environment
right like if you're um i don't know if
it will work but my prediction would not
be that it would work in the opposite
direction but that you would have
um
just a lower reduction in infrared if
you are trying to keep
uh
heat in as opposed to keep heat out but
well i may be wrong about that seems to
me that there are there are two things
in play and you know i am officially way
out of my depth here but um the
window uh what do they call them
uh the window units the sealed um the
sashes now no the sealed double pane
they have some there's some term that
they have in the industry you know you
blow one of these things we're both
looking over there like will it will it
reveal its name
no it will not reveal its name to us
perhaps if we shout at it um but those
sealed units right those that's an
insulin which like and and
double-paned with a with a gas station
with a gap and it's not just a gap but
like often isn't there specifically a
gas i don't remember what inert gas
right forgotten what it is
might be nitrogen but um
but anyway the point is those sealed
uh windows are obviously insulative and
they're insulative you know
the old joke uh i'll spare you the joke
um but the uh
the the
pre the catholic priest the protestant
minister and the rabbi are discussing
what the greatest invention of all time
is they haven't walked into a bar
they're just talking well they're
definitely in a bar okay um
and uh
the uh
the catholic priest says it's the it's
the printing press i'm apparently not
gonna spare you
the catholic priest says it's the
printing press because it allows uh
knowledge to be uh distributed over vast
distances uh you know enlightening the
world the minister says no no it's the
wheel which allows the burden of man to
be
greatly reduced in the facilitation of
his work and the rabbi says no it's the
thermos bottle
and they look at him and they say well
what's so great about the thermosphere
he says well it keeps hot things hot and
cold things cold and they say and he
said well how does it know
um
okay but anyway the point is that
yeah
the point is for those just listening i
was laughing it was really inaudible
yeah
i think they heard you
they heard you um but anyway the point
is the window is insulating and it could
be keeping your
near infrared generated by whatever
heat generator you've got in your house
in in which case it could be a benefit
it does raise all sorts of questions too
about what of the types of heating that
we have in our homes are generating
near-infrared i'm sure i'm sure this is
known whether or not what is known as
accurate but i didn't have time to look
into it but it you know feels to me like
radiant heat is you know maybe going to
be like i don't think so okay i don't
think so for the following reason um
if let's say you have hydronic floors
yeah okay
so radiant hydronic comes in multiple
you can have radiators you can have
radiators high on your wall you can have
radio you can have tubes on the floor
let's talk about the floor okay
one of the things that's actually good
about radiating radiant heat in your
floor is that you don't actually have to
heat the whole space in order for the
human to get it because for one thing
the human tends to be on the floor
rather than the ceiling you hit the
solids rather than the gas right
you get thermal mass right and the other
thing is if you're like us and you're
shoe free then you're picking up a lot
of heat through your feet and so your
blood is warmed and you feel warm even
if the room is a bit colder than it
might be and so the point is well that
doesn't give you very much of the
benefit that is predicted by
this result here because that result is
about your entire body being
irradiated
um and so i would guess that hydronic
floors are actually probably not so hot
with respect to uh interesting yeah your
near-infrared well-being yeah um well
and i just barely got into it but um
so i'm not going to
to say much about it here except to say
that uh the awesome
rhonda patrick has written a paper and
done a video on this same medcram um
site
the paper with co-author johnson called
sauna use as a lifestyle practice to
extend health span actually
published in experimental gerontology
which is where your telomere work was
published
back in the day and this is just a brand
new paper 2021. uh so anyway there's
this of course leads to like what what
might begin to explain all of the very
many health benefits that we are now
coming to understand about sauna um and
you know you know what kinds of sauna
what kinds of what kinds of uh
regularity all of this well this this
does lead down that road and we don't
we're not going to go there today
because i didn't have time to fully
explore it but but imagine you knew
right imagine that you know you knew
you know that you had instead of the
tyrannometrics [ __ ] where you've got
like well how many lumens does it put
out
right you've got like well what's its
net effect on my life right right this
bulb you know if we could end up back at
tungsten
and
you know you might live longer and
happier and all of that and sleep better
all those things totally
um
okay so this the zimmermann and writer
paper that uh that resulted i wish that
we were talking about with the with the
decrease in near-infrared radiation that
we're being exposed to over time since
basically since before the industrial
revolution um since we've moved more and
more inside with more and more
protection from the sun
they basically they propose what we've
now already been talking about but their
hypothesis this is published in 2019
um is let me just give a little back up
is that melatonin and sunlight are
linked we know this
but melatonin comes in two forms i've
already said this but i just want to be
very
formal about it circulatory and
subcellular which have very different
relationships with the sun so the
hypothesis that they propose in this
2019
paper that's published in the journal
that i had never heard of before called
melatonin research
is
circulatory melatonin is produced in
response to the absence of sunlight
and subcellular melatonin is produced in
response to the presence of sunlight
which itself is you know remarkable that
the same hormone is going to be produced
by opposite
opposite triggers you know the sa it's
the same input and it's it with a binary
state of yes there is or no there isn't
and in each of those states a different
a different source of the melatonin is
triggered to produce it now i will bet
that there is a
elegant story
that unites these things that it's not
just contradictory but it's a little bit
like you know the uh the result
um
uh that the triggering of your body by
adrenaline
activates certain things it speeds up
your mental processing for example and
shuts down your gut right right is it an
up regulator or a down regulator well
it's a i'm running from that scary thing
regulator and yeah
and the point is different thing you
know some things get put out put off in
that circumstance and other things get
amped up
and my guess is going to be that the
reason that melatonin is showing up in
both places and the reason that the
pattern is inverse is going to be one of
these like hey that's your your awake
system and then
etc by the way your awake system would
need to know something about your sleep
system and vice versa right exactly so
here's just a couple of paragraphs from
near the end of this 2019 paper
published in military research and you
can show my screen if you like zach
sunlight and the optical properties of
our surroundings guaranteed that for
millions of years most cells in the
human body especially in children were
always exposed to predominantly
near-infrared photons during the day and
for six hundred thousand years as groups
gathered around the campfire in the
evening before bedtime
this continued for the last 150 years
based on the excessive amounts of near
infrared radiation emitted by
incandescent bulbs
fifty years ago fluorescent bulbs
started to eliminate near-infrared from
the artificial environment but the
incandescent lights continued to provide
near-infrared especially in homes
recent government mandates have begun a
process that will for the first time in
the history of our species eliminate
most of the near-infrared exposure that
once dominated
these changes are being driven by
government mandates and will be
universally implemented over the next
couple of decades with 90 percent of our
time under artificial lighting and in
front of displays that emit zero
near-infrared and with near-infrared
blocking window treatments preventing
near-infrared from entering our offices
schools and homes
modern societies have created
near-infrared caves
as figure s9 illustrates most
researchers are aware that we are
eliminating night by exposing ourselves
to excessive amounts of visible emission
in our signage street lights headlights
lighting computer screens and displays
what most researchers did not realize is
that for the first time
seventy percent of the spectrum emitted
by the sun through near in the form of
near infrared is being eliminated from
our lives during the day
and just one more thing as the roundup
lawsuits clearly illustrate there is an
added level of responsibility and
liability associated with globally
altering the public's environment
as shown above the human body has
evolved and adapted processes based on
the assumption that it is exposed daily
to a single predominantly near-infrared
broadband fixed emitter the sun
that assumption is no longer valid over
the next several decades the government
will convert all lighting to
visible-only emitters with little
understanding as to the long-term health
consequences
um or stated otherwise
hyper novelty is a cold [ __ ]
and i thought actually um there's much
more to do here but i thought actually
to read the epilogue to our book here
because it fits we didn't we didn't know
this yeah when we wrote this book um
this is
a hunter gatherer's guide to the 21st
century um we didn't know what i just
read uh here um
and oh actually one more just show that
final screenshot from the medcram video
zack
if you would before i read the epilogue
here
um
he says we need to start doing
randomized controlled trials on sunshine
exposure
being outside and wouldn't wouldn't that
be a thing yeah right wouldn't that be a
thing and it would be um cruel and
inhuman to restrict some people to
inside if almost everyone weren't doing
that to themselves already anyway
right okay this is the afterward uh it's
just two pages uh from hunter gatherer's
guide to the 21st century
in january of 2020 and so just a
reminder um
we
submitted the first draft of this book
in march of 2020 just before
lockdowns began from covid and of course
it went through a you know a number of a
number of reviews and edits and such
but this book was written the fast bulk
of this book was written before covet
was a known thing but the afterward was
written afterwards
in january of 2020 we went to the
tippatini biodiversity station in the
ecuadorean amazon to finish our first
draft of this book when we emerged from
our isolation as our phones came alive
for the first time in two weeks we were
confronted with a barrage of news mostly
trivial of which we have been blissfully
unaware
but in that onslaught there was one
ominous report a case of a novel
coronavirus in ecuador the pathogen came
from horseshoe bats had jumped to people
and then spread rapidly first in wuhan
china and then beyond
as the two of us tried to make sense of
these first hints of pandemic it quickly
became clear that there might be more to
the story
wuhan we soon learned housed a bsl4
laboratory it was in fact one of our
planet's two main centers of research on
batborn coronaviruses
these viruses were being studied in
wuhan in north carolina because of fear
among scientists that such viruses could
jump to people and without very much
evolutionary change caused a dangerous
pandemic if nothing else the fact of the
pandemic having begun in one of two
cities where these viruses had been
under intensive studies seemed
spectacular coincidence
as of the writing of this note in late
may 2021 the consensus in the scientific
establishment including national and
international regulators and in the
mainstream press that follows them has
finally shifted to one of grudging
acceptance of the obvious i will say
that it has since shifted backwards
somewhat
um sars kovi ii may well have leaked
from the wuhan institute of virology and
the covet-19 pandemic might therefore be
for humanity an entirely self-inflicted
wound
the strength of this hypothesis is
something we have been discussing on our
podcast darkhorse since april of 2020.
those discussions caused a great deal of
derision and stigma to be directed at us
and it is a bewildering relief to watch
the world suddenly come around the
plausibility of this well-supported if
unfortunate explanation
but no matter what humanity ultimately
concludes about this pandemic's origin
there is a deeper truth hovering just
outside our collective awareness
covert 19 is a product of technology no
matter what path it took to humans
consider this fact
from the beginning of the pandemic the
virus showed essentially zero capacity
to transmit outside
put another way copen 19 is a disease of
buildings cars ships trains and
airplanes
more than 99 of the earth's surface is a
coded safe zone
even in your own backyard the virus will
struggle mightily to infect anyone it
has no meaningful impact unless you
caught it before you walked out in the
park on the balcony at the beach we are
at least for now immune
the dependence of the virus on enclosed
spaces also means that had humanity
agreed to avoid these vectoring
environments for a few weeks the
pandemic could have been quickly brought
to a halt
but this scenario in which we free
ourselves and lock down dangerous
environments instead is little more than
an idle thought experiment
even though in evolutionary terms these
dangerous environments are all brand new
to humans the idea of humanity staying
outside of them even for just a few
weeks is unthinkable
many individuals could do it but the
majority would be at a total loss even
though we evolved outside and despite
the fact that most of our ancestors
would have spent every hour of their
lives in what we now strangely call the
outdoors
we have forgotten the skills we once
knew so well that knowledge of and
comfort with our natural environment has
been replaced with a different skill set
one tuned to pursuing value and avoiding
harm in a synthetic environment of our
own device
our cognitive software has been
rewritten and we have forgotten too much
to ever again be what we were as a
result we are condemned to battle this
pathogen in bespoke environment
environments and which we and it have
been both grown to depend
that's the view on the ground but the
human dimension of this pandemic is even
clearer from thirty thousand feet or
more accurately at thirty thousand feet
for it is the way that we have begun to
travel that really set us up for
pathogenic disaster
sars kobe 2 crossed oceans and hours and
it didn't pioneer some ingenious new
mode where once an epidemic might have
been held back by barriers that limit
human travel humans now regularly
transmit communicable diseases from
their continents of origin to every
corner of the globe
much as people thought little about
washing their hands prior to the germ
theory of disease we give no thought to
the scale of misery caused by a given
person transporting a new and nameless
cold virus to some continent that was
free of it the day before
novel coronavirus took advantage of that
nonchalance before the pathogen even had
a proper name
the copen-19 pandemic is itself a
symptom of another disease entirely in
the pages of this book we call that
disease hypernovelty
it is caused by a rate of technological
change so rapid that transitions in our
environment outstrip our capacity to
adapt
you will not find the coven 19 pandemic
specifically dissected here but you will
find a full exploration of the hyper
novelty crisis that left us vulnerable
to this virus a virus so weak that it
could have been cured with a bit of
well-coordinated fresh air
so
patient again
i think yeah not uh
it's a little bit
it's a little bit chilling uh
to hear that analysis from was it may
2021 oh yeah we wrote that in may of
2021
um yeah it's uh you know
yeah
i
hate to keep patting ourselves on the
back but uh prescient again
um at many different levels you know um
so
we are where we are i wonder where we'll
be a year from now indeed indeed
uh so there's one more thing um that you
wanted to one more topic that you wanted
to talk about that i think you know kind
of wraps it up kind of wraps it up yeah
so go for it those of you who follow me
on twitter and really why would anyone
not follow me on twitter
um but those of you who follow me on
twitter know that i have been i have a
reason you do yeah uh because you're not
on twitter
not because you're not on twitter oh
people would not follow you on twitter
because they are not on twitter and and
good on you if you're not no i think the
only people who have that excuse are
people who've been booted off twitter of
which we know quite a number no no
absolutely not you know i disagree with
this yes
but nonetheless
um anyway it does make the uh the excuse
more robust
but
anyway those of you who follow me on
twitter
uh have noticed that i have been uh
exploring the question of sophistry
which we have talked about here uh uh
extensively as well why am i exploring
the concept of sophistry as my
stupidest detractors have suggested is
it that i just learned this term well no
in fact it is not i've been talking oh
good that's off history forever but it
has become more and more relevant as you
my dimwitted critics uh have brought it
to center stage but in any case
my point about it is this
i have been exploring it because many of
our um
our best fellow travelers are i think a
little confused because one does not
want to imagine that you are up against
sophistry and so for example i saw colin
wright
grappling with the question not a
sophist not a sophist grappling with the
question of
why he wasn't steel manning gender
ideology and his point was because i
can't do it very well because
in any case point is what i said was
look you're not obligated to because the
assumption that brings steel manning
into the question involves the person
whose position you're steel manning
actually believing it and nobody
believes that men and women aren't
different we all get this and so when
somebody says well men and women they
aren't different it's a continuum right
when somebody makes an argument like
that you're not really obligated to
steal manner etc but
anyway that this is all just uh um
a a run up to the question
uh that i really want to address which
is this
sophistry begins in ancient greece right
the sophists were tutors
okay they were tutors for hire
and i want
ironically enough i'm going to steal man
the sophists okay
some of the sophists may indeed have
been bad people maybe they all were we
get the connotation that they are bad
people
because they attacked socrates
and um
plato
who is really the conduit through which
we get socrates
basically holds no truck with this
garbage that they apparently hurl
but as tutors i want to point out that
sophistry potentially is a it's maybe
the one defensible context for sophistry
because
the presentation define the term again
yeah sophistry is the deploying of
uh specious
arguments that are structured to be
difficult to counter right
so the sophists
so as an educational tool as an
educational you're about to say it is
marvelous that's really useful it is
really useful i hurl this at my students
who i've hopefully just educated some
stuff and see see what they can come
back with right and although i
swear that i didn't know this until
recently in thinking back to how i used
to teach i actually used to deploy this
i would say things
that i knew weren't right and
my purpose was not to fool anybody my
purpose was to make it uncomfortable for
a student who knew better to sit there
and listen to me say things that weren't
true so that they would challenge me and
i would say
you know well but i mean you did this um
i i did it too but like i had less of a
stomach for it um
you would do it without acknowledging
that you were speaking what you knew to
be uh ridiculousness no i and and you
and the idea was
that it was absolutely 100 incumbent on
anyone in the classroom who knew that
what you were saying was batshit crazy
or even just subtly wrong you know and
you know batshit crazy is easy to go
after but subtly wrong like oh boy you
know i don't like i've been either i
just met the guy today because you
started right off the bat like you would
do with this from day one but you know
even a couple weeks a couple months um
in some cases you know we had students
who we knew for years um years later it
can be it means that
they you can't just sit in the room and
go okay if he's talking if she's talking
um i don't have to keep my brain alive
and i could just sort of let it wash
over me it's like no because at any
moment there might be something embedded
in the argument that's actually not
right you have to be assessing and no
i'm not trying to get you to not trust
me i'm trying to get you to um to always
always have your own self-reliance and
and intellectual self-reliance turned on
yeah i want you to trust me but i don't
want you to trust your reflexive trusted
me right i'm not gonna con you and tell
you something i don't think is true and
let you hold on to that but the
important thing is that when a student
got up the
the gumption to say
that's not right and i would say sure it
is and i would defend my point and then
they would have to counter it and at the
point that they finally had me cornered
and they'd shown that i wasn't right and
i'd say exactly right
then every other only occasionally did
they race this rush the stage and grab
you by the lapels right only rarely but
the point is every other student in the
room then got the idea ah
this is the classroom where i'm supposed
to be looking for the thing that isn't
true in a series of things that isn't
true i'm supposed to be looking for the
thing that isn't true and the thing is i
don't think there's a better educational
tactic than that right so anyway
i have steel mandis office i believe
sophists are often terrible people but
these sophists may have been decent
people they may have been good educators
and there are certainly people who
employ sophistry in the educational
context
that are doing so with noble intent and
hopefully if they do it well with good
effect
here's the fly in the ointment
i don't have
obviously a window into all of the
classrooms of the world at the moment no
one does but i do have information that
comes to me from various places about
what is taking place in classrooms
there has never been more sophistry
in classrooms right
the problem is that sophistry is not
delivered
with the intent of getting the students
to rise up and in fact if the students
challenge the sophistry
right they are punished we know this yes
and so
i am concerned that the value of
sophistry
is
lost and that the opposite of that value
is being amplified at an incredible rate
yes i would expect
i would expect in every classroom there
would be some student who just couldn't
stand it anymore
i couldn't stand to hear this nonsense
and even though it was going to be
costly to do so i would imagine in every
classroom somebody would say hey teach
you're just wrong here's how you know
right and the fact that it doesn't
happen says something about the
the type of environment that we have
created now i'm i
want to be clear i'm not
saying
hey students what's wrong with you why
aren't you standing up because i know
that uh the the danger of them doing it
is
real yeah no one i and we have both
heard in fact i just heard this last
week of a
of a story
out of a classroom
in which
a female student um stood up to
um some you know not even the worst
you've ever heard but just like banal
gender ideology
and um had a different take you know
wasn't
you know it's like you know a good
liberal undergraduate student who had a
different take and she was forced to
leave the room she was forced to leave
the classroom um the the professor in
question had so little capacity to have
any dissenting opinion at all in the
room and that feels extreme
but i don't think it is
right
now the question though is if if we're
really
correct
in
our
you know our taking the temperature of
the culture
if we're really right that school after
school classroom after classroom
sophistry is being discussed every day
and well that
sophistry isn't being discussed no sofa
tree is being enacted sophistry is being
deployed and not with the intent of
in
upgrading the minds of the people who
are being taught bad arguments
for which it is nearly impossible to
which is nearly impossible to respond
are being deployed by the authorities
who come in with their terminal degrees
and the ability to give you the grade of
their choice
and those arguments are just being
required to sit there as if that is the
god's honest truth and um students are
neither
being allowed to reject those arguments
um nor being allowed to
learn how it is to
to desist and to argue against them
right
and
my my real concern is 20 years from now
right as bad as things are at the moment
if you've taken an entire generation and
you have successfully created enough
fear of standing up and saying i'm sorry
that's nonsense right i mean i used to
do this and i did pay a price for it but
i didn't pay a price in every classroom
right the point is it was it was a
trade-off and i got a lot out of it
um
but
we now have an entire generation that is
being trained
even if you know better
don't say so right right that saying so
will be catastrophic for you
then
um
you know and i i should say occasionally
you will see somebody
uh will
um prank the sophists
right they will deliver a speech that
you know uh
it's hard to reduct or add absurdum
something that starts out as absurd but
they'll do it anyway and it's you know
it's a good comedic effect right or some
kid at a school board meeting will stand
up and describe this appalling thing but
it's you know
it's
ten thousand as many students as you
would expect
right
right if you ran the experiment in a in
a normal
in a normal year right a year 25 years
ago
if you had ran the experiment of
introducing
um pervasive nonsense in every classroom
in the nation all simultaneously you
would have had a rebellion wouldn't have
been every student but you would have
had somebody in almost every classroom
call it out
and
we have created an environment that is
too perilous for that to happen and the
cost of that will be paid for
generations it will indeed of course um
what you just described is not how this
happened either it's a it's a slow
a slow creep a slow change in
expectations and
you know if we're being honest um
you you were very rare
uh yourself as a student you know
it was
it has always been
classroom the vast majority of classroom
cultures
uh to
to highly rate order and compliance
uh the more so the more you know the
higher the student to faculty ratio and
the younger the kids and
the more
out of their skis the teacher the
professor is in terms of how much they
know and how smart they are and you know
all of these things predict an
environment which like you know what
just sit down shut up take notes yes it
will be on the test i'll see you
tomorrow
and you know that's not educational i
don't think anyone ever thought it was
but um it does provide a certain order
and people are less likely to get into
fist fights in such classrooms if if if
that compliance is adhered to yeah well
i i agree with you and you know there's
of course
the value for the creation of that order
and you know it it's a pendulum question
at some level
so for now let us just say
uh
damn the sophists beware the slow creeps
the slow creeps all right
okay well that uh that takes us to the
end for this week but we will be back in
a few minutes with a q a
uh and then not back again with another
live stream episode until once again
it's gonna be may 26th but there will be
some more darkhorse before then and
there will be a q a coming right up uh
ask your questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
if you have logistical questions about
anything if you have questions about
where to ask your questions um i'll tell
you the email address to send those
logical
logistical questions too which is
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com but really
if you're just looking to ask questions
of us
it's again
darkhorsesubmissions.com so right here
um again we appreciate um the support
and we encourage you to subscribe like
share talk about
our subscribe to the channels like the
videos share and talk about this this
work this content with your friends you
can consider joining our patreons for
which we are very grateful uh if you
like that little excerpt from one
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century pick it up read it it's
available at libraries it's also going
to be available uh in both french and
spanish
starting either the end of this month or
in june and in many other languages
within a year
and
yeah without further ado
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside
see you around the warm warm campfire
[Music]
you